نعم في الواقع وسيله هذا هو حال
كراماتورسك اليوم التي فاقت على ليل دامن
يمكن ان نشاهد ما حصل في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا التي تم اطلاق صاروخين روسيين من
طراز كي اتش 22 استهدافات هذه المنطقه
يمكن ان نشاهد عمليه الاطفاء ما زالت
مستمره في هذه في هذا تحديدا في هذا
المجمع قتل رجلان واصيب اخر بجراح يمكن ان
نعاين حجم الاضرار التي
خلفها هذا خلفها الاستهداف الصاروخي
الروسي لهذه المنطقه التي تعتبر منطقه
تخزين للمواد الغذائيه
التي بالاساس تتعرض الى قصف دائم من قبل
القوات الروسيه حجم الدمار الذي لحق بهذا
المستودع الكبير نتحدث هنا عن برادات تحفظ
اللحوم
وغيرها من المواد الغذائيه التي تشكل مركز
ثقل اساسي لتوزيع المواد الغذائيه في كامل
مدينه كراماتوسك التي دائما تعتبر احد
المراكز الرئيسيه للقصف الروسي الذي
يستهدفها هذه المنطقه هي منطقه شاسعه
تعتبر مخزنا لكافه المواد والغذائيه
وغيرها من المناطق المتواجدين عن اطفاء
مستمره حتى الان الساعات حيث تعمل هذه
مكافحه
التي كانت قد اتت على مساحات واسعه من هذا
المجمع
نحن هنا نتحدث عن 20400 متر مربع من
المنطقه التي تخزن فيها يخزن فيها الطعام
كانت ليله صعبه بالفعل على مستوى كروموسك
وغيرها من المدن على هذا الخط ضمن المنطقه
الشرقيه نشاهد عمليات الاطفاء المستمره
بالاضافه الى فرق الانقاذ التي كانت قبل
قليل هنا تحاول البحث عن اي
ناجين محتملين او عن اي ضحايا يتواجدون في
داخل هذا المجمع الكبير الذي تعرض كغيره
لعمليات قصف من قبل الصواريخ الروسيه
عمليا القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه كانت
تحدثت عن اربعه وعشرين صاروخا
مجنحا استهدفت 13 مقاطعه اوكرانيه من
ضمنها قتل سقطوا هنا تحديدا في كراماتورست
المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه قال بانه لم
تتمكن الدفاعات الاوكرانيه من صد هذه
الصواريخ التي وصلت الى هذا المكان لانها
من النوع البالستي الذي لا يمكن اسقاطه من
خلال الدفاعات الجويه التي تمتلكها القوات
الاوكرانيه عمليا ما حصل هنا يختلف عن
الصواريخ التي اطلقت من القاذفات
الاستراتيجيه في مناطق اخرى على سبيل
المثال
سقطت صواريخ من طراز اس
3400 اما هنا فكانت الصواريخ هي من طرازات
معدله تستخدمها القوات الروسيه بالاصل
كانت صواريخ موجهه نحو حاملات الطائرات
تستخدم لاستهداف القطعه البحريه ولكن
القوات الروسيه عدلت هذه الصواريخ وباتت
تتساقط في هذه المناطق وتحديدا هنا فكره
مال الانقاذ يحاولون ازاحه ما يمكن ازاحته
على مستوى الركام الممتد هنا تم انتشاد
القاتلين من داخل هذه المنطقه تحديدا
والان عمليات اطفاء وتبريد
رجال الاطفاء ومن بعدها تتوجه فرق الانقاذ
للبحث عن اي ناجحه محتملين يتواجدون هنا
عمليا الرائحه كريهه جدا لان الانبعاثات
من هذه المواد المحترقه وهي مواد غذائيه
كانت تستخدمها تستخدم اما على مستوى
الامداد الغذائي لكامل مدينه كما توسكو
ومن تبقى فيها من قبل السكان او للامدادات
الغذائيه والمساعدات التي تنقل الى مناطق
اخرى وتحديدا الى بلدات دروسكيف كاب
المحيطه بهذه المنطقه حيث نتواجد هنا نحن
عمليا في المنطقه الشرقيه التي باتت خلال
الفتره الماضيه تواجه هجوما روسيا كبيرا
على مستويات متعدده سواء في كوبيانسك
مرورا بضمن هذه المنطقه حيث تحاول القوات
الروسيه احداث خلق على مستوى خط الجبهه
عمليا كانت قد تحدثت قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه وايضا نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني التي بان الوضع في هذه المنطقه
الشرقيه بات صعبا وهذا ما كنا نلمسه مؤخرا
من خلال التطورات على الجبهه سواء على
المستوى العسكري عند الخط صفر من المواجهه
والالتحام بين القوات الروسيه والقوات
الاوكرانيه او على مستوى القصف الذي يطال
كافه هذه البلدات المتواجده هنا على مستوى
الخط الذي يعتبر الخط الثاني وهو خط امداد
وخط استراتيجيه للقوات الاوكرانيه من جهه
ولكنه بالاضافه يعتبر احد المراكز
لتجمع كافه المواطنين الذين فروا من خطوط
المواجهه الاماميه لاسيما على مستوى
البلدات التي تتعرض الى قصف دائم
شكرا جزيلا لك مازن ابراهيم من
كراماتورسك من المنطقه التي تعرضت الى هذا
القصف والذي نرى اثار الدمار وعمليات
انقاذ من خلفك اشكرك جزيل الش